intelligent robots will play a big role
in future industry advanced machines
like these can respond swiftly to
changes in the production system many
industries are counting on them to
completely take over the cell row
company in the Netherlands is a
specialist in intelligent robots which
don't need to be stopped and retooled
when a new object comes down the
assembly line yes in possibilities are
almost endless it all depends on what I
want to make how big is it what tools do
i need to i want to make it out of
aluminium or do i have enough tools to
use other materials to the company sells
about twenty percent of its output to
customers in germany it also tailors
software to automatically coordinate
production systems that's important when
making small numbers of things such as
medical technology products you branch
of the businesses that need flexibility
the most and not the ones that engage in
mass production they're the sectors that
have to react quickly in their markets
one product today another product
tomorrow yes more than what he does
Dutch companies have a long history of
innovation 10-count it was founded three
centuries ago and it's had to adapt to
changing markets this factory was
formerly used to weave fabrics for
bridal gowns today it's used to weave
carbon fiber cloth which can be molded
into any shape ones of a fuzz off a
wound vac stuff is in our fiber
composites are made to be processed
further that's what makes them unique
they're highly suitable for the
production of standard parts for the
aviation industry it's the smart
irrigation it they call it organic tin
it's extremely light and used for
components in the Airbus a380 passenger
jet carbon fiber components are also
being used increasingly in the
automotive industry their light weight
is a key factor in reducing
fuel consumption the horsey area life
gets most of our production is now going
into the automotive industry in Germany
the alien fazool components are being
tested in prototypes and data is being
collected so the automotive industry can
build cars with it as a damn it
constitute year at the end of februari
Alfa Romeo signed a deal to buy enough
of ten contas high-tech fiber to build
4,000 sports cars the flashy design is
unmistakably Italian but the chassis is
classic innovation from the Netherlands